[Music]
so you're basically just building a
mansion yeah basically how confident are
you I am 80 certain I'm not confident at
all a bit weak
I want to make it so that everybody can
be a property investor but the hardest
part about getting into property is lack
of Finance that's why today I'm going to
be investing my hard cash into your
property deals alongside my brother
Russell who's also been a property
investor for 12 years and my
brother-in-law Ben who's been a
chartered cost manager and been in
property and construction for 16 years
we're going to be using our money to
fund and finance your property deals but
will anybody tempt me enough to invest
in their deal let's find out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I am pitching a flip it's a three
bedrooms attached house and looking for
a no money down deal I want the
investment because I will gain the
knowledge of the mentors gain the
knowledge of doing developments itself
and being able to project manage as well
I am feeling nervous but we get in there
hopefully it all goes well
[Music]
what I want from you guys today is to
invest in a big three-bedroom detached
house uh worth five hundred thousand
spend uh money on the refurb as well
whilst I project manage it
um I have just got an email today saying
I I am able to get planning on that from
a planning consultant and what I want
from you guys is just I want to work
with you guys for the knowledge
be able to work with you one-on-one and
basically just learn tricks and trick
tricks tips and tricks throughout the
trade
yeah thank you Charlie so what's the
vision with the property then is it just
doing it up or no no so my vision is
refurbing inside which will cost I think
around about 60 000 Mark is a probate
property as well also try and add
literally double up the property really
add a another thousand square feet onto
it I'm really confused because you've
said gdv you've put worst case 600k oh
that sorry that's if you just wanted to
refurb it
right that's if you just wanted to
refurb it so what's the extent so you're
but you're going to extend it my vision
I want to go bigger and better really I
want to I want to uh extend it how much
is the refurb just the refurb alone if
you didn't get planning UH 60 000. so if
you bought it for 500 000 and spent 60
and then it was worth 600 you'd be
absolutely stuffed wouldn't you
[Music]
who have you spoke to what which
planning consultant just the local one
near where the house is it's a planning
and Architectural uh company just out of
curiosity obviously it's next to a
Greenwood enlisted church have they
taken that into consideration yeah they
have I've uh I've taken out in
consideration I've told them all about
it because from my experience when
there's a grade one listed or grade two
listed building next door
it makes it very difficult to get yeah I
mean because you're in you know in in
the area of that building I've got my
house at the moment that I'm living in
yep it's next to a grade two listed
building okay and I can't even get
Juliet balconies on okay they're really
really strict so I mean I know you spoke
to a planning consultant which is good
is it a planning consultant or an
architect they're in or the same they do
it together in there but it's actual
planning Consultants yeah I spoke to uh
no I did speak to planning Consultants
and what are you thinking to draw what
is it to build I want to add two more
bedrooms so even that's to a two bedroom
uh two-story out the back and build
obviously build up and have a bedroom uh
and then have like a big one-story area
with big
doors open plan it's pushing the value
up our question is how confident are you
on the gdv of being a minimum of what
what did you say nine hundred thousand I
think uh 880 I've put as a worst case as
a word how confident are you that that
is a worse case if you were to get
planning to extend it
um I am 80 certain I'd like to think
foreign
nervousness around getting planning yeah
and the worst case being that you know
if you didn't get planning I don't think
there's enough margin in there to make
it worth the hassle I agree only
exception to that would be if we spoke
to our planning guy and he said that he
thought he thought we would because me
looking at it right now
I'm not confident at all you'd get
planning I think it's just a little bit
of uncertainty around yeah yeah I'm
planning I like you and I do I don't
think it's a bad deal I think it's got
potential but I wouldn't be confident at
this stage to say yeah let's go ahead
yep on that basis
not this time bro but you're gonna win
and I look forward to seeing you do well
and maybe on a future deal
[Music]
that one person you're right for myself
uh unfortunately I didn't get the deal
I'm gonna keep pursuing this property
just because I'm going to put a bit more
put more due diligence in it and what
planning I can get from it and then
potentially I'm going to sell it
[Applause]
my name is Joshua alajo I'm pitching two
amazing bras investment on these
projects will be absolutely massive it
would be a huge endorsement from these
guys that I'm doing some good work and
I'm finding good deals I didn't come
this far just to get this far so yeah
I'm all in for the investment
so today guys I've got two amazing deals
to present I'm telling you about the
Northampton one first so it's a brr
property
um it's on the market at 2 30. I've been
speaking back and forth with the agent
for the last few weeks and believe I can
get it at 170. the refurb on it will be
like 50K and the GDP on it is 270.
what are you wanting to sell this
package and sell yes I wanted to package
and sell it but then also I wanted to
sort of I wouldn't mind project money I
put an option for me to project manage
to do it because it's like two minutes
from me I've Got The Power Team in place
I can do everything the hands-on
experience that's fair enough and all of
that stuff so five grand finders fee
five grand project management yeah yeah
to look after to look after it that's
fair enough listen it's a very solid
deal it's not a pull all your money out
deal so it's not like oh my gosh
yes please can't turn it down deal is
there nothing going better not a good
one the vendor's going through a messy
divorce
um so the husband occupies the property
so there's no there's no photos of
inside the property or that no one's had
access to inside the property so what
I'm trying to do is take advantage of
the fact that she wants a quick sale
it's below market value
what I'm proposing is that
do you guys put up the purchase price
and I will take care of the refurb from
my speaking with the agent the husband
lives in the property he's lived there
for 10 years I don't think he's a
hoarder or he's it's just a bit of about
the divorce I think that the refurb is
just going to be modernization and it's
going to be like it's not going to be a
full refurbs it does say on on the
market
the the app the evaluation estimate is 1
16 of the property
I did I use square meters comparables to
sort of work out what things were going
for in the area because ours is a it's a
Terrace house but it's the end Terrace
so it's detached so I used other
um detached semi-detached to it um
comparables in the area to sort of work
out the GDP
[Music]
I think I prefer the I think one first
one yeah a bit more cash in work up
front it is more cash in I work up front
but then you return it your return is
better in it there's more money to be
added there's more value to be added
that one's just
bit weak
what was the gdv again on the on the not
on this one on Northampton to 270. it
needs about 50 Grand why have you not
already sold this like if you're just
wanting to get a finders fee why have
you come to us so I do have some
investors already interested the agent
has not confirmed the price what's
happened is they said best in finals and
then the company decided they would show
some more people the property so it's
still sort of so they've they've done
shown it again to more people I do have
investors in the wings but working with
you guys is sort of an opportunity I
can't sort of pass up you're not really
working with us though are you just
selling us a deal for five grand I'll
show you what if you did the project
management then obviously I would have
be able to sort of yeah you know call in
on your knowledge and I'll be getting
Hands-On getting the experience see oh I
like that I'm looking at the others in
the street and I am confident that the
value would be close to 270.
I'll tell you what I like the fact that
you've done your DD with the building as
much as you possibly can yeah um and
it's not just a finger in the air you've
actually actively spoken to people
personally if we can get that at one
seven day I'd be happy to buy that at
170. would you ever saw yeah would you
man yes and I'd be happy to pay a five
grand finders fee and I'd also be happy
to pay a five grand for each of them
project manager so if we if you can get
that wrapped up okay I'm happy to do
that yeah okay
yep fantastic thank you
[Applause]
they went for the brr in Northampton
which is a case of me selling them the
deal and project managing it as well I
mean obviously all of their knowledge
and experience you know is going to be
invaluable when in with two deals I sold
one so yeah I'm buzzing you know
[Applause]
my name is Jax I'm pitcher for firebed
HMO Coventry investment will mean a lot
to me because it builds up my own cash
to be able to invest myself because I
haven't got the chance to do that just
yet I'm excited for the outcome of it
and what their opinions are of the deal
[Music]
cool so it's a property that is a five
bed hmm Coventry is just shy of the city
center of Coventry itself it is
currently tenanted it's currently
managed HMO license in place
it is structured as a HMO so there's not
really much major work needed to be
doing for it to change around but in
terms of the potential rent I've had a
look on spare room and it can range
between 450 or 550 per tenant in terms
of what I'm looking for
I'm happy to sell the deal or to
whatever you got offered in terms of
joint venture really
it's just a HMO isn't it really yeah
basically it's not um
it's not like an amazing deal really is
it yeah I'll be honest if you buy this
yes you might get a 17 return on your
money which is very decent yeah but it's
not like you can pull your money out or
anything like that is it
[Music]
and I'm sure that there's lots of
investors that would pay you a couple
Grand two or three thousand to take this
deal on yeah but we just bought a house
in Coventry yeah where it's very very
similar to this the only difference is
we're going to refurb it and pull out
nearly all of our money so it'd be hard
to justify buying a deal like this I
think there's better deals out there
yeah so for that reason I wouldn't want
to go ahead with it
I know there's investors that would bite
your hand off to buy that for three
grand yeah but I think there's better
deals out there yeah yeah and there's
other people that have come to me today
with better deals
but it's solid you're a cool guy so I
hope you I hope you sell it elsewhere
quiet but there's other investors are
interested anyway so it's not a lost
situation it's a window situation he
didn't say he didn't like it he said it
was more standard there's not much to it
in terms of his other deal like he said
where you can't pull your money out of
which I completely understand I'll go
forward with the universe and see what
they say and then just take it from
there
[Applause]
so my name is anus Scott Williamson and
I'm a pitching for joint venture a Land
Development I am feeling real nervous
but investment will mean a lot to me
it'll just mean you know Financial
Freedom for me and for me to be able to
do a lot more for my community
my name is aniska Williamson and I'm
actually here for a joint venture on the
Land Development I've actually found a
development in Richmond which is a
really beautiful era it's just behind
Richmond Park it's got planning
permission for a six bedroom house the
purchase price for the land is one
million 100
and the the development itself is
costing between 800 and 950 but the gdv
is between
2.73 million nice so you're basically
just building a mansion in the most
beautiful part of the world in the most
beautiful part of the world I do want to
show you guys this is the most exciting
I've been
[Music]
how much money are you able to put in
yourself so um I was hoping for really
to be honest with you 100
Finance 100 development but um I do have
a bit of cash behind me that if I needed
to I think you have to the reason I say
that is because you found it online on
the open market it's like to be getting
the percentage of The Profit just by
going oh I found a Rightmove link it
does it's not a fair
but if you're putting money in and then
we're putting money in and then we're
also maybe getting some development
finance and then doing it as a joint
venture we can obviously we've got all
of our skills and experience
so we could definitely do something yeah
I mean the figures work I like it but
what we'd be able to bring to the table
number one is we'd be able to appraise
it and make sure that nothing goes
obviously there's always some risk but
make sure that if we're Partners you've
got our full backing on it so we're
going to get all our reports we'll
project manage it and what I would
suggest what I think person would be the
fairest way to do it would be
whatever money you put in versus what we
put in that's how we go so if you only
put 250 in and we end up putting a
million in or if you put 400 Grand in
and we only put and we put 400 and we
put 400 Grand in as well and we can get
the rest on development points then we
go 50 50 but we just do it on a basis of
what we've put in that's how I would
propose would be the cleanest and
fairest way to do it if you're happy to
do that I'm personally happy to go ahead
okay
I like it and I like you you like it
thank you
showing a lot of due diligence has gone
through all of it in fact you've looked
at Finance yeah feels really confident
so yeah I'm happy to go ahead great next
steps is going to be we'll meet up have
a coffee Ben will view it and we'll get
the ball rolling and put an offer
forward right okay you happy Ben yep
happy yeah happy I am happy family Great
Well Done congratulations
I'm excited because I actually just got
a deal a joint venture with several
leads so we're developing a six bedroom
house and full reception room and a big
development the gdv is great so we are
all going to benefit at the end of it
[Applause]
[Music]
if you want to see this show happen
again then do me a favor hit the like
button if this video gets 200 likes I'm
going to be doing part two of this
series don't forget to subscribe to the
channel if you want to see more videos
that we've done like this you can check
out our playlist right here and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the eviction
2022.
over the next few weeks you're going to
have a series of very intense property
investment challenges and the winner is
going to be given 20 000 pounds cash
prize to help kick-start your property
investment Journey
with the help of various mentors that
are going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges I'll decide who stays
and who gets evicted
because you needed to be spoon fed wow
just don't lights man don't call me
alone I'm not going to lie down and take
it
can I have a break
about the Coronation Street isn't it
you're evicted